hey welcome to weekend ticket where
we'll be showing you what's new in
theaters this weekend what's new to
watch at home on Fandango now but let's
start off by talking about the biggest
box office numbers from this weekend The
Invisible Man has been cited all over
the US the Blum House update on the
classic HG Wells story open do 29
million this leap day weekend that's
good enough for not only the highest
debut of a horror film for 2020 but also
the highest horror debut since it
chapter 2 last September the social
thriller stars Elisabeth Moss and only
cost 7 million to make so the positive
word-of-mouth should stand to make a
hefty profit and potentially reboot the
universal monster series that was
refashioned after The Mummy
underperformed in the u.s. in 2017 the
anime movie my hero academia heroes
rising had a plus ultra debut week
taking 10 million since its debut on
Wednesday February 26 the popular
Japanese manga franchise follows a group
of students who are aspiring to become
professional superheroes at the hero
Academy this is the second
feature-length film in the series which
also has four television seasons on its
report card
and finally bad boys for life seems to
be box-office top 5 for life the Will
Smith Martin Lawrence action comedy
surpassed 400 million worldwide this
weekend and it will surpass 200 million
domestic within this very week the long
overdue sequel has become the highest
grossing film of the year so far
but each film has left past the other in
regards to global box office with bad
boys to having the previous franchise
high of 273 million globally
on to its new in theaters this weekend
we start off with the long-awaited 22nd
film from Pixar onward in this brand new
story set in a fantasy world two teenage
elves find a magical staff and use its
magic to bring back their father kind of
now the two and a half family members
must set off on a journey to complete
the spell before it wears completely off
of course this is a Pixar movie so it
has a huge a list cast this one stars
Tom Holland Chris Pratt Julia Louie
Dreyfus and Octavia Spencer just to name
a few and as you'd probably expect from
a Pixar movie you might cry when asked
Chris Pratt suggested bringing four
boxes of tissues which like one that's
pretty emotional and two at that point
just bring a beach towel
I'll cried hearing the pitch to this
movie it's very emotional it's very
moving I don't say that it's like a
selling point because I know that this
movie does who's gonna sell itself its
Pixar everyone knows Pixar they know you
know Finding Nemo they know up they know
Toy Story and I think though the reason
I was so moved and why I tweeted about
grown-man tears is this is a
relationship about brothers it's a
relationship about longing to meet a
parent that you've lost and just those
themes resonate throughout and they're
very moving and it's rooted in dan
scanlon real story the way back also
hits theaters this weekend
in the film Ben Affleck plays a
washed-up alcoholic former high school
basketball star whose life has fallen to
pieces when asked to take on the role of
coach for the current basketball team he
sets off on a path of redemption for
both himself and the team of struggling
players Ben Affleck has said filming
this movie was an extremely personal
experience for him as the character
shares a few parallels to his own self
and he even got his weight up to 245
pounds in an attempt to get closer to
where his character's physical state
would be
[Music]
now let's see what's new to watch at
home on Fandango now first up we've got
Jumanji 3 aka Jumanji the next level
which sees the return of the rock Kevin
Hart Jack Black and Karen Gillan as well
as new players Danny DeVito and Danny
Glover longing for fantasy of the
Jumanji world
Spencer jumps back into the game
concerned about their friend the rest of
the gang jumps back in - but this time
they're forced into different avatar
bodies even worse Spencer's grandfather
and his grandfather's old friend gets
sucked into the game - now they must
somehow work together to face new
challenges without dying to things like
mandrels ostriches snakes and of course
cake Jumanji the next level currently
has an audience score of 87 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes and in case you need to
catch up on both Jumanji and Jumanji
welcome to the jungle they're both
available on Fandango now and honestly
if you haven't seen the original Jumanji
you should just go do that right this
very second Oh unless you're afraid of
spiders ah they probably already left
Queen and slim is also available to
watch at home when a couple on a date
has an intense run-in with the police it
ends with an officer dead now on the run
the couple has to trust each other and
strangers as they unintentionally become
a powerful symbol of the community
Jodi Turner Smith plays a defiant lawyer
named Queen opposite Daniel kalui as
character slim the film marks milena
mat-su kisses featured directorial debut
Matt sucsess is known for her work on
HBO's insecure and has directed several
music videos for Beyonce and as far as
awards season goes Queen and slim has
won nine awards to date including for
black reel Awards that's this week's
weekend ticket leave us a comment and
let us know how you think
onward and the way back we'll do in
theaters this weekend I'm Cale anonymous
and I'll catch you next Tuesday with
more box office numbers new releases and
new movies available to watch at home on
Fandango now
[Music]
[Music]